hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess tournament we
are in the third match in uh yani ponchi
versus anish giri
and uh yeah for some reason in the
previous video i mentioned
that um anish won the the second match
and
uh he was able to retaliate and force
match three however i i said that he
won in the rapid section when in fact he
won in armageddon i have no idea why i
said that
that's just how it is on this channel
sometimes i'm gonna say the weirdest
stuff
uh so don't take it personally yeah i
and i i i am sorry about that
so uh getting back to this one this is
the third match
it seems the image is blinking a little
bit changing colors no idea
uh why that's happening uh but yeah uh
the
four rapid games ended in a draw so the
first four rapid games ended in a drop
the first
blitz game ended in a draw and now this
is the second blizz game
and the whether this one ends uh in a
draw or not will depend on do we go into
armageddon
so yanipam she went to the white pieces
opens with e4
and yeah sorry about that uh so e5 by
geary uh and now
knight to f3 we have knight to c6 and d4
for the final blitz game jan goes for
the scotch
and if if you don't know the blitz games
here uh in the legends of chess
tournament are uh five minutes per
player a plus
three seconds increment so e captures on
d4
and knight captures on d4 we have knight
to f6 and
now uh knight captures on c6 we have b
captures and e5 going for the
mises variation of the schmidt of the
scotch and now
queen to e7 pinning the pawn so you
can't capture
with queen to e2 now preparing to
capture and knight to d5 and this
has been played well for a very long
time
uh the top move being c4 we already
mentioned this a few videos ago
uh but nowadays uh h4 and it's very
interesting how
uh you know just the neural networks are
are taking uh
uh well so so much for from the game i
mean player
you can't really learn how to brute
brute force your way through a position
now by
imitating stalkers but you can learn a
thing or two uh from leela about opening
theory and the positional stuff
so here h4 we have a5 uh usually
uh white will play c4 here like we
mentioned and then black wants to reply
with
bishop to a6 but here as white already
wasted a move playing h4
black will now play a5 so when he does
play bishop to a6 he will already have a
pawn on a5
so c4 by nepo and the bishop to a6 by
gary with knight to d2
and uh here we have knight to b6 and
interestingly
knight to b4 has been played once in
this position alexander morrisey which
lost to dimitryakovenko in the 2017
russian blitz championship
so knight b6 here by geary is a new move
in the position and it is already as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game
so nepo just continues pushing his past
h pawn then not a past h1 just
just an h pawn and that's what you do
nowadays
in every opening we have queen to e6
geary makes room to develop the light
the dark square bishop and now even
h6 another thing is uh if g6 which
obviously can be played you're going to
play b3 put the bishop on this diagonal
and the neural network such as lilac
chess 0 showed that this
will definitely be a great asset for
white later on in the game
so after h6 we have g captures on h6 by
geary
it's not the cleanest pawn uh but
it is it is still a pawn up so you're
gonna play bishop here probably bring
the rook over to the g
file and for the moment keep your extra
pawn so b3 by nipple he just continues
development wants to
develop his dark square bishop to this
very nice diagonal and a queen side
castle by geary bishop to b2
continuing development and now bishop to
g7 and
a queen side castle we have rook h the
e8
now putting a lot of pressure on the e5
pawn and of course f4 now nepo defends
it
and now we're in a position where black
has to decide what to do
uh the bishop and the knight aren't
doing all that much nepo did a very nice
job
this c4 pawn really uh putting uh
putting a stop to everything and
probably what you should play something
like d5 or maybe d6
uh but gary wants to save his uh
save his central pawn and bust open the
position with the f pawn and he plays f6
and it's always interesting when someone
plays f6 whether this is one of those
positions where it's actually okay to
play f6
or not so here it's not and you're
welcome to
feel free to not welcome to feel free
but you're either welcome or you are
feel free to pause the video
and find the movie nipple played while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
knight move as is just
brilliant and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's knight to e4
and it's interesting that giro already
spent
some two minutes uh from his uh five
minutes uh starting position
whereas nepo just blitzed out everything
so this is well within his preparation
and he knows what he
what he's doing here so here uh the
problem is you're threatening knight to
c5 which will attack
the queen and then win the bishop on a6
so of course you cannot defend with the
king as then the king also runs into a
fork
so what you could do is play bishop to
b7 to kind of prevent that but then you
just get e captures on f6 and now this
is a defended pass pawn
it's just a a very very tough position
for black to play you don't really have
a good move you can move the bishop but
that's just it if you go for trades here
uh it doesn't work work out well for you
you're gonna capture on g7 and then
after let's say captures an f4 you're
going to capture here capture that
play rook h8 and it's it's game over so
this is what nepo is hoping for
uh giri finds a different idea gary says
okay you capture my bishop i'm just
going to play f captures on e5
and okay nepo goes forward knight to c5
with an attack on the bishop and the
queen
uh and giri spots queen to f5 he wants
to meet the
uh knight captures on a6 with uh e
captures and f4 opening up an attack on
the queen and
under bishop here and the queen the king
could be somewhat loose here
on c1 so nipple goes for it knight
captures an a6 and
e captures an f4 opening up an attack
here
so you have to move the queen and here
nipple goes for queen to d3
it's hard to imagine from a position
like this but
queen to d2 is actually the the way to
victory
uh the point is uh you want to be able
to play c5 and
defend your knight on a6 that's how you
need to play it point is that after this
captures and captures
and let's say the king attacks the
knight you always have this c5 move and
it's now
uh perfectly fine as the knight is
defended
and your knight is also under attack you
will have to move it then comes queen
captures on a5
and so on and it seems like queen to d3
does pretty much
everything the same it even offers a
queen trade
the problem is it it is a little bit
different because here
uh gary first placed bishop captures on
b2 with czech
king captures and now queen the e5 with
check
now uh point being that uh the king is
in check and you have to
you you have to figure out what what
you're going to do for example if queen
blocks then you can just capture
captures and then bring the rook to e5
and the rook from e5 will guard
the c5 square so the knight cannot
escape on the other hand
uh you could also uh block with queen to
c3 which is what nepo did
but now gary gets his uh his idea into
the game king to b7 now threatening to
the win the knight here uh and here the
problem is if you go c5 now
then it doesn't really work because
black has queen captures king captures
and now knight d5 comes with
check the king is no longer on b2 like
in the live line we've shown
and after king b2 now you get knights to
e3 and you will have to give up
the the rook here because if you move
the rook let's say you well
rather you will have to give up the rook
even here after check king moves you
have to give it up now
because if you don't uh if you try
something else uh
you have to give it uh you have to
capture it instead of moving the king if
you do this let's say knight e3
then you're gonna well either move the
rook you lose the bishop and then after
the bishop is lost
king captures on a6 is coming so the
thing is after king
to b7 with queen captures uh on e5
by nippo uh and now rook captures an e5
guarding that c5 square
and here just rook captures uh on h6 and
now okay you cannot capture right away
because then just check we'll pick up
the knight here
but it does allow c5 so this is the
little problem
that why queen to d2 was better than
queen to d3 what nepal played
but uh obviously you can't have
everything analyzed at home and you know
in a blitz game
uh things like like like these are
impossible to find
so here uh the knight is lost so you
might as well grab a pawn while losing
it so knight captures on c5 with rook
captures and now rook captures on h7
and all of a sudden from that really
really winning position from white we
we get this position where white is
better a bit more active uh but the
position the the material on the board
is completely equal
so here rook to f8 defending the the
pawn here
and now bishop to e2 not allowing the
spawn push
but also preparing bishop to f3 which
blockades the black pawn and also puts
the bishop to this beautiful diagonal
uh we have d6 by geary c6 is the way
the way to go then we move the king and
then maybe move the the
the deep one however geary played d6
here and it's a really an epic moment in
this game
because this uh completely blunders the
pawn rook captures on d6 is a free pawn
uh you will not be able to capture back
because because
uh you know of the pin problem is uh
nipple of course uh
when playing such an elite player like
giri does not it does not expect uh give
it to
blonder upon like this and of course he
misses the idea and he just continues
with the development of bishop to f3
check
and uh it's uh i mean this happens very
often in chess and
there's even the case of i i hope you
all of you know josh waitskin
uh i remember when i when i was enjoying
his um
uh his lectures in the chess master
series i think it was just master 11 the
grand master's edition
uh he mentions that he was playing in
some sort of a junior state championship
and that he was playing for the
for the first place and in the final
game he was playing against an opponent
who
hang a full rook who hung a full rook
and
josh just didn't see it he was uh you
know so focused on the game and he
didn't expect his opponent
he like attacked the rook and his
opponent didn't move it he just played
something else
and both of them completely missed it he
said his opponent
after the game told him that uh he
immediately saw that he blundered the
rook but that he was like having this
super cool poker face so that josh
wouldn't you know realize that something
went wrong
so josh missed it but indian was also
able to win the game so that's like
like a happy story in the end uh but
yeah it's not uh
uncommon to blend or move like that as
this is a blitz game you know
stuff stuff like this happens way more
even in classical chess
so bishop to f3 check sometimes called a
case of double blindness so bishop f3
check we have king to b8 by giri and
now rook to e1 preparing rook to e7
which will pose serious problems for
black
so knight c8 preventing the rook lift
all the way to e7 and now
rook to e6 uh a nice rook lift
uh which will uh you are now just
preparing to somehow double up here
so rook to g5 and now king to c3 nepo
brings the king into the game
we have rook f2 g8 and now
uh rook to f7 going after the f4 pawn
and it seems like you can't defend it
however there is a very sneaky way and
you replace it
rook to e5 saying if you capture here
then i get a defended pawn here and if
if you go after it i'll just defend it
like this and everything is perfectly
fine
so after rook e5 we rook the h6
now preparing to bring the rook over to
h7 to put pressure on the
on the c7 pawn and here it's like it's
like
giri fell asleep uh in game six after an
entire day of playing
uh he played a4 and he just completely
forgot about uh
nepo's real threat which is doubling of
the rooks on this uh on the
seventh rank so here rook hd seven by
nippo and now
uh there really is not all that much you
can do guilty played a captures on b3
we have rook captures on c7 now
threatening rook b7 check and if the
king has to go
uh you know under under the mask of the
bishop that's
that's just game over so rookie three
checked by giri we have king to b2
and now you you cannot allow rugby seven
check so here gary just captured
the bishop gave up the exchange g
captures and b captures on a2 but now
with king captures an a2 and rook to g3
here gear is now hoping to create a past
f pawn but rook b7 check king a8 and
now comes rook b3 defending the pawn
with rook g2
king a3 and now rook to c2 going after
the c4 pawn we have rook to be
rook the c7 is also playable just
defending it and winning the knight
so not not a problem there uh or rather
okay
you don't have to win the knight for
example rook c7 knight a7 and then you
can go rook to b6
but it requires some some additional
some additional moves uh so instead nepo
just went with rook to b4 he defends the
pawn and he's going to win the knight on
the next move by playing rook to h8
so rook c3 check king a4 or rather not
k4 king
king to b2 attacking the rook rook
captures an f3 and do not rook to h8
just attacking the knight uh the knight
of course cannot move
uh and that's just it gary played a few
more moves rook f2 checking c3
and he was in this position on mu 45
that anish geary resigned the game
and with it the match as after four
rapid games that ended in a draw one
blizz game attended in a draw
uh nepo wins uh uh nipple wins uh game
two of their blitz section and is now
the finalist of the chess 24 tournament
of legends
uh and will face magnus carlsen in the
finals
and uh yeah that's uh that's it uh
tomorrow we continue with
with this show uh with the well i don't
know who i would rather see in the
finals
both both geary and nepo against magnus
would be would be excellent
uh but i don't know i i always kind of
feel like like nepo has
better chances against magnus but it's
also hard to say because giri
i think giri is a more solid player than
nepo but uh
magnus doesn't care about solid like you
have to you have to do something to to
beat him and i
i kind of think nepo is uh somewhat
better at that i don't know
uh you know in classical chess i i think
of course giri would have
much better chances but here i don't i i
don't think so
uh so yeah uh well it's gonna be a
pretty pretty wild
uh game so i will see what happens uh so
i
i do hope you enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank uh larry dingle james moore
patrick moore thomas moore and
diva mohanarangan for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the legends
of chess tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your sunday